[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
va parler de justice ou issus sévèrement
gardée le procès de l'ex général salan a
pris fin sur un verdict qui a exclu la
peine de mort notre reporter n'a pu
filmer que l'atmosphère des couloirs au
tour du défenseur de l'inculpé m tixier
vignancour satisfait mais rompu par
trois heures de plaidoiries et l'émotion
de voir sauver la tête de son client
ce verdict a causé dans les esprits une
agitation dont les journaux de toutes
les opinions se sont fait l'écho quelles
répercussions aura demain cette décision
de justice nouveau problème qui s'ajoute
à tous ceux qui ont course entre
l'algérie le plus urgent est celui des
réfugiés le hall de l'aéroport de maison
blanche et jour et nuit l'asile de
centaines de familles en partance pour
lesquels un pont aérien a été établi
chaque jour maintenant une dizaine
d'avions de ligne ou la rotation alger
marseille déversant à marignane leur
cargaison doit ya jeunes la peur du
lendemain l' angoisse du présent donne à
cet exode ces raisons et ses réseaux
noces sont ils ces migrants une minorité
bientôt absorbé sont-ils l'avant garde
d'un retour plus massif
en mettant à leur disposition un bloc
d'immeubles en construction dans la
banlieue de marseille le gouvernement
s'est appliqué à parer au plus pressé
avant de prendre les mesures
d'adaptation et de reclassement qui
s'impose déjà l'amorcé de ce
reclassement peut s'apercevoir en
camargue une propriété de 40 hectares a
recueilli le bachaga boualem sa famille
et ses familiers 66 personnes en tout
menacés sur leur sol ils ont choisi
l'exil peut-être ici le seigneur de
loire se lisait ses fidèles dont il
refaire leur patrie
[Musique]
oh
e
le chapeau ceni à la mode de bretagne
il n'est plus possible de l'éviter nos
élégante auront cette saison des
chapeaux
transformable ou simplement déformable
inéluctablement rond inéluctablement
petit breton ce couvre-chef admet
cependant chez jean barthet des
interprétations diverses c'est ainsi que
le bloc ne ferait pas et s'adjoint en
toute modestie une rose géante que le
hall on pend fait généralement très bon
ménage avec le petit breton classique
des petits bretons il y en a du reste
pour tous les goûts et pour toutes les
personnalités il y en a deux sages de
réserve et il y en a aussi de délurée
le bol se voient souvent assorties des
efflorescences printanière et se prête
aux interprétations psychologiques de
leur bref dans sa variété la mode du
chapeau rond plaît il est pour s'en
rendre compte que d'aller observer le
rayon déjà peau d'un grand magasin
parisien où jean bart et a ouvert son
rayon les pubs et les petits boutons on
se les arrache positivement
telle est la force de cette nouvelle
mode
[Musique]
mais le long des chapeaux ronds comme
dit à peu près la chanson if demandé
breton
[Musique]
président de la toute jeune république
islamique de mauritanie monsieur moktar
ould daddah rendant visite à la france a
été accueilli à son arrivée par le
général de gaulle
la république islamique de mauritanie
qui est l'un des états africains à qui
la france a donné l'indépendance a on le
sait une place de choix dans le contexte
international
ce qui impose une importance
particulière aux entretiens qui ont
réuni à l'elysée les deux interlocuteurs
[Musique]
le geste traditionnel de l'étoile à
donner son sens à cette visite le
président mokhtar ould daddah n'at-il
pas dit à son arrivée la mauritanie a
fait une longue route commune avec la
france qui a accompli dans notre pays
une oeuvre dont elle peut être fière
un an de plus pour le festival de cannes
sophie des marais la seule femme du jury
et le ministre de l'information monsieur
alain peyrefitte ont clôturé cette
quinzième épreuve de fond qui a vu et
demi je payais remettre la palme d'or à
anselmo duarte le réalisateur du film
brésilien la parole donnée
restait très ouverte jusqu'au bout et
c'est sans doute pourquoi le prix
spécial du jury a été décerné ex-aequo à
l'italien antonio ni pour l'équipe et
aux français robert bresson que
représentait le directeur du cinéma
monsieur fourré cormerais pour le procès
de jeanne mas 21 jours et 20 nuits le
festival et à l'an prochain
[Musique]
le twist encore le pis on croyait
l'épidémie en voie de régression elle
continue de se propager et bien non pas
de signaler à berlin un concours de
twist qui prouve que dans l'ex capitale
allemande la maladie est en pleine
évolution
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les caméramen eux-mêmes ne semble pas
avoir échappé au virus faudra-t-il
envisager une conférence au sommet
[Musique]
l'amérique a vécu sa deuxième journée de
l'espace il est 4 heures 40 à cap
canaveral un gentleman en combinaison
argentée sa petite valise à la main
prend l'ascenseur du cosmos à la 11è
passerelle l'attend la capsule mercury
aurore septe scott carpenteyre va
rééditer l'exploit de glen trois tours
de la terre un événement banal en somme
et pourtant journalistes cameramen et à
travers l'amérique et le monde sont
saisi par l'émotion quand le jour paraît
et que sans l'être pesant la fusée atlas
la première fois un télescope permettra
de suivre le moment crucial de la
séparation de la capsule et de la fusée
lors de la mise sur orbite
elle est finie
maintenant comme il ne fera trois fois
40e prague autour de la terre
sa voix précise que tout va bien à bord
ni tels que jean nuit du à la
température
[Musique]
et c'est la fin du troisième tour
ralenti par ces lettres aux fusées la
capsule rentrer dans l'atmosphère on va
perdre le contact radio quelques minutes
mais la circonstance est prévu
cette fois pourtant le silence se
prolonge il se fait pesant il semble que
la main d'oeuvre n'est pas été parfaite
et le fait est que la capsule touchera
l'océan à 300 kilomètres du point prévu
le suspense dura 54 minutes finalement
on apprendra enfin que des plongeurs
parachutistes ont été largués au dessus
du point de chute un avion a dit le
communiqué officiel a repéré la cabine
et à côté un radeau de sauvetage quand
un gentleman qui al'air confortablement
installés confortablement semble
d'ailleurs superflu l'amérique respire
scott carpenter a accompli sa mission
[Musique]
trente millions de recettes et 40000
spectateurs à toulouse pour la finale de
championnat de france de rugby entre
agen maillot blanc et la hesse béziers
jeu rude des biterrois qui veulent se
faire respecter résultat un coup franc
qui leur coûtent trois points dès le
début du match
cela n'empêche pas béziers équipe
complète et bien équilibré sous la
conduite de son maître à jouer pierre
danos de prendre l'ascendant sur âge au
cours de la première mi-temps ascendant
qui se traduit par ce très bel essai sur
mêlée tournée que mal en même temps les
huit avants biterrois essai transformé
auxquels s'ajoutent quelques instants
plus tard un but de pénalité béziers
mène donc 1 8 à 3 lorsque débute la
deuxième mi temps et sans plus attendre
de dieux marquent un drop 11 à 3 le
match paraît gagner pour béziers et
c'est là que le miracle se produit ce
miracle il est caractérisé par cette
attaque des agenais qui étouffent leurs
adversaires la descente est arrêtée qu'à
cela ne tienne elle repart de l'autre
côté avec tous les trois quarts qui
ponctue par un essai de mérite
il en sera ainsi tout au long de la
deuxième mi-temps béziers qui perd
toutes les balles à la touche n'a plus
qu'une solution défendre défendre à tout
prix son avantage et les attaques ne
s'arrête jamais merrick bouclé recentre
au pied l'un de ses avants a suivi ça y
est 11 à 9 on est maintenant quasi
certain que les agenais vont gagner
d'autant qu'il ne ralentissent pas le
rythme merrimack un nouvel essai
transformé 14 à 11 agen est champion de
france
m
[Musique]